hundreds of veterans have come forward
after a cbs news investigation revealed
new evidence of toxic material at a
remote base the u.s military used after
9 11. now according to the defense
department
more than 15 000 american troops passed
through the base known as k2
to support missions in nearby
afghanistan now nearly 2500 current and
former service members report rare
cancers
or other illnesses they believe are
linked to those deployments
senior investigative correspondent
katherine herrich recently spoke to one
k2 veteran
who says his illnesses have baffled
doctors for years
she's at the pentagon with more on this
story catherine it's got to be so scary
and so unsettling to be ill and nobody
can tell you what's wrong with you good
morning hopefully you've got some
answers
well that's racial good morning our
investigation was cited during recent
congressional testimony
that's put new pressure on the va and
defense department to acknowledge a link
between time served at the base and
illness
the air here is poison army veteran mark
jackson's deployment journal is a raw
and unsettling account
of his time overseas the ground and the
dust that covers it is contaminated
everywhere is decay and environmental
degradation
jackson's journal documents his 10
months at karshikanabad or k2
after 9 11 u.s forces used the former
soviet air base in uzbekistan
to hunt al qaeda in nearby afghanistan
every yellow tab is a day where i felt
sick how many doctors
have told you that your illness is
related to toxic
exposure at least five that i've spoken
to
they believe that it has to do with the
exposures
and what they did to my body when i was
in my 20s
more than a dozen k2 veterans told cbs
news about
toxic conditions from soil saturated
with jet fuel
a running track marked with warning
signs to this site
nicknamed skittles pond for its changing
shade
two years after jackson left k2 his
health
quickly deteriorated i went from being
able to run a marathon and not be able
to walk up a flight of stairs
turns out my thyroid simply did not
function i was 28 years old
now the 43 year old takes a cocktail of
drugs to manage his symptoms
and sees his doctors on a regular basis
i see an oncologist once every six
months
just to make sure that nothing else is
cropped up that's why
i call it a ticking time bomb a federal
investigator by training
jackson has gone to capitol hill to
support a k2 veterans advocacy group
the stronghold freedom foundation on its
facebook page
members self-report rear cancers and
other illnesses
just under 5 000 k2 veterans our members
half have some sort of medical
issue in october our team revealed new
evidence
about k2's toxic history and a defense
department eyewitness came forward
we learned that the soviets had had
a chemical weapons decontamination unit
adjacent to our camp the impact from the
cbs investigation was immediate we had
hundreds more reach out to us some of
whom are very sick
and all of whom thought they were alone
but neither the defense department
nor the va acknowledges a link between
k2
and illness is that a betrayal of course
it's a betrayal they promised
they promised to take care of us after
we raised our right hands
and promised to take care of them
testimony you're about to give
a recent congressional hearing cited the
cbs news investigation
that profiled a former air force
mechanic and k2 veteran whose cancer
caused brain damage
mr wilson rides a mile and a half in a
mechanical wheelchair twice a week
to attend his physical therapy
appointments in a rare show of
bipartisanship
lawmakers pressed the va and defense
department witnesses
on the lack of action these veterans
need help and they need it now
the va's continued denial denial has
left hundreds if not thousands of k2
veterans
ineligible for certain preventative
health programs and unable to receive a
disability benefit
while a long-term study is ongoing the
v.a maintains
there is not enough scientific evidence
to make the connection
it would be a disservice to the veterans
to simply say and this is all veterans
to simply say
[Music]
we don't know how you got it we're just
going to cover it my office looks at the
science i want to find out
what the exposures were u.s forces left
k2
in 2005. satellite images from earlier
this year
show the area where troops worked and
slept appears abandoned
the most telling part of that to me is
that in 15 years
the uzbeks haven't moved a stone why
they know it's poison why else wouldn't
they use half of their own base
while six pieces of legislation are
pending jackson says
the acting defense secretary and v.a
secretary can take action on their own
help you can help us this is a cry for
recognition
recognize our sacrifice we are still
sacrificing a senior pentagon official
tells cbs news that the acting secretary
of defense
is considering a number of options to
provide immediate help to the k2
veterans with the goal of addressing
their issues
in the coming weeks tony so glad we're
covering this and those satellite images
certainly catch your attention catherine
thank you very much